there we go
uh what a LED well with the Rugby World
Cup just around the corner there's only
one man we all need to hear from right
now he was the one who was responsible
for keeping the country calm as he
guided the All Blacks to the 2011 Rugby
World Cup as well as being one of the
all-time all-black greats he's also a
true Wellington and hurricane Legend who
has also had stints for Auckland and the
blues London Welsh the wasps in England
and a couple of other clubs that are
hard to pronounce in France and of
course he finished with the mighty wide
upper Bush since footy he's been the
star of his own TV show he's also been
on the reality show match fit for a
couple of season now everyone knows that
he has a lad he's actually one of the
great Lads it is of course welcome
brother thank you brother I don't know
about the intro is a bit hold on then
not too much
we all know you're a very humble man I
know you don't even really talk about
being an all black and all that sort of
stuff anymore you like to keep it very
low-key oh
you've been obviously been talking to
some of my uh cousins and uh and Friends
well I don't speak too much about my uh
my career much but yeah do people still
recognize you out on the street and
stuff yep I actually um had a few people
ask me for a photo the other day but it
was it wasn't because of the foot it was
because of my TV series now oh true yeah
oh we watch your show all the time and
I'm like sure
oh that's cool though hey you've still
got that um identity within the public I
guess yeah and plus like more recently A
lot of people have been slagged or not
slagging me mostly all my mates anyway
I've been going to a few function I've
been rocking up my rib end so they're
slaying me when I when I'm like going to
a uh tidy event everyone's wearing suit
dress shoes and all that and all Morty
boys rocking up with bloody red bands I
don't see that actually
where was it it was like a function
somewhere right with Collins yeah lady
yeah yeah it's lady in Forsyth bar uh
had organized a uh a breakfast and there
was
um Jonah and Victor were sort of on a on
a panel and uh Kim was there and um I
think I spoke I've spoken to a few
people since then I said they're
probably the I'm the first person I've
ever seen walk and walk into the
Wellington club with a red band
and an event that looked very very uh
tidy
you couldn't convince Victor to wear
their red bands as well
oh no I think I uh because he seen me a
week before the uh at a at a luncheon
and I was rocking my red band spinning
and he was like you know actually
I couldn't get away with it I said
that's because you're a scotch education
mate your Scots college education
wouldn't allow you to wear something
like that
you could bring it back how good would
that be everyone just wearing gum boots
to functions save the dress shoes the
worst shoes ever as long as they're not
bloody uh dirty usually like if they're
putting from being out on the farm or
trying to act like I go hunting is just
put them at the front door and you're
rocking around rocking your socks
and obviously you're out all the time
now doing are you still um recording
your your show
uh not at the moment like we've we've
finished
um edit that I've finished editing the
TV series and uh that's going to go to
air in October true is that season three
uh season six season six holy yeah yeah
well the dream the the Bruce um idea
Bailey's idea was to um try and have 71
episodes yes
um been I played 71 test and I thought
oh
is that a stretch Catholic are we going
to be making another part but I think
you know I think this year might have
been
uh uh they're they're about something
all right how cool is that are you
loving it oh yeah absolutely it's been
it's been awesome like just you know you
go to people talk about all these places
um and
you know you just sort of just flow and
fly up you don't actually get to meet
like the actual people that live there
on a day-to-day basis kind of thing so
meeting heaps of locals that just love
hunting for sure dive and just Gathering
food
but not only that they don't just just
do it for themselves they actually you
know give it out to the community too
yeah and that's been the best part about
it the most rewarding part is that
every person that I've gone out with you
know they've all got something in common
which is they might go out their freezes
might be full so they're just going
through everyone else's freezes all
right let's go away and like the best
thing is like when you go to someone
that
um does hunting you take Seafood to them
bro you come back with like venison and
wild pork it's so good
and then vice versa everyone that lives
on the or near the ocean you know if you
take wild meat to them yeah they'll
happily take that off you for a bit of
Kai all right how good is that and how
did that even um come about how did you
fall into the whole Penny's Ticky tours
oh
I got asked when I was living in
Auckland
um from Bailey if I'd be interested in
you know presenting a TV show
am I even
gonna be good enough to sort of present
the TV series
um
but then I ended up signing and going
overseas yeah so I ended up I was like I
forgot to tell them that you know he was
like
um what happened to you sorry because uh
I'm just gonna go overseas for a couple
years and have a have a news yet in the
competition and then uh if it's still uh
on the table then yeah sweet but yeah
had a corridor when I was living in
Auckland went away come back from
overseas and
um the network we're pretty Keen Maori
TV was still Keen to well they asked to
follow still King and I was like
here sweet okay that's us yeah so
yeah started from about three years
beforehand
um and then when they said if I was
still interested I was like I'm not
doing anything else yeah why not might
just keep myself busy yeah and what was
it like doing it we were you nervous um
presenting and hosting your own show
especially the release I'd imagine a
like probably more so releasing it to
the to the world well you you think
about it when we're all those years of
us through press conferences conferences
for like you know bloody media and all
that we're real short and sharp with our
answers yeah yeah so we don't give us
too much away I remember the first one
the first episode we did which was down
in um
my family's from and um I did all my my
cousin and my uncle
and um they were asking me questions in
my master interview and I was real short
with my answers just because you know we
that's what we've been told like three
things yeah exactly three things make
sure you push these three subjects and
then just keep hearing and honing in on
that so I was real short and short with
my answers and because the best part is
my older brother was a camera operator
oh true so bully was
um then he was like hang on
wait you can actually open up it's not
like media you know where you're a real
short and sharp thing is straight away
yeah and um after that it was I felt all
good after that I guess it helps when
they have my older brother there the
whole time yeah so it's been good we've
been sort of doing this together oh true
so he's he's one of the filming on the
on the show yeah so he's um he's worked
for TV3 for for years because he used to
come up to training up at rugby league
park and you know try and pick an angle
where he's trying to say that I've got
the fattest ass in the family by getting
shots of me
you're looking really awkward right now
with uh some of these pictures but
um yeah he did there for a while
for years and then I thought you know if
they asked I was like I only do it from
older brothers the camera operator
we've been doing it together since all
right and just plans to keep going keep
keep on rolling oh maybe a movie
no no way we've already done it Troy
king he was me oh it's true they picked
the perfect guy I mean my my voice is
real good not
but um well at the moment like we're
sort of in a in a stage where after this
season
um the funding hasn't sort of uh isn't
going to continue
um but what we're going to do is try and
find
um see if we can find sponsorship around
I know it's a bit tough at the moment
with a bit of a recession and all that
but we're going to try and figure out
how we can make a plan to see see if we
can still continue the dream surely well
with all the well-led listeners
listening who love
um the show they'll be getting in behind
you and surely it will keep going
forever that showed is one of the greats
but one thing I am Keen to hear from you
is a little bit more about your
upbringing I know you grew up in
wainuiomata and people love it out there
it's a pretty cool Community when you're
involved by the sounds about what was it
like for you growing up out there
ah man that was it was awesome
um
I guess you don't sort of have the
freedom that these kids have these days
where you can just walk down the street
with a ball and your mates and
uh we probably shouldn't have done a few
things like pass the ball across the
road to your to your cousin or your man
on the other side of the road and try
and do it before a car comes um it's how
you got your Quick Pass
oh don't don't hit the woodscreen but um
I mean I've got
uh lifelong friends that I grew up with
um you know some of them played in the
NRL
um
I started one of my uh well my other
best mate in the with our rugby career
together with namir
um so we started to get in 2003
literally retired well I wouldn't say
retired but we pretty much finished our
career to give in narborn yeah
um
but uh it was it was awesome I mean
my second home other than mum and Dad's
house was uh the league club Winery
league club oh yeah and so you know
tyrell's Dad was there Johnny but his
his three brothers of well four there's
four of them but the Lomax family is a
you know a big part of
um our league club and our and our
family up there uh Kim Laban as everyone
would hear him he's
um
you know one of the commentators for our
MPC and Super Rugby was on the uh the
World Series for for the sevens
um Tana so tana and the me and myself we
pretty much started our our careers at
uh at the league club everything really
was through the league club and then um
it's quite funny because we all started
but we all became all blacks too
um with a massive League background
um tyrell's the same Tara grew up uh
playing League do you remember him as a
kid
yep because he's he was hanging out
quite a lot with my um with my nephew uh
they're they're Josh they're pretty much
the same age so those two are like this
and they still love today
um but he was just you know I used to
live quite a bit at my auntie's house
with my cousins or at my grandmother's
um
and
when I had a
as well and so sometimes he would walk
past my grandparents house pick me up
we'd go to school after school would
come back
because my grandparents are like always
um trying to feed all my myself and my
mates and all my cousins he used to just
go and help himself he was part of the
furniture so here we're coming in a
couple other mates that I grew up with
that live just around the corner too
they'd come over have a feet go home and
be like getting a growling because the
bloody had a massive feeling that all
that Bloody thought it was so hot you're
not supposed you're supposed to hide all
the evidence mate
but um I enjoyed my upbringing to my new
small community
um pretty much everyone knew everyone I
was running around and at the league
trainings as at the age of five uh
following my dad and then obviously bore
both of the loan rip back in the long
red days in the late 80s early 90s
um
and uh you know
we had guys that went over to the NRL
wall
um Yogi Rogers Ellie Davies
um David Lomax and obviously Johnny as
well Tana had a chance to go
um but he obviously
come home got about home said come home
and
I guess the risk this issue with him
yeah become one of the great uh as a as
a player for the Hurricanes lines in in
the ABS so is that how you sort of moved
into Union as well were you watching his
path or how did you end up going to
Union ah not by choice true mine I went
to boarding school and all they had was
rugby oh yeah so I went to a Maori
boarding school uh called teote and in
the Hawke's Bay and um
before I got there my older brother had
already been there and they knew after
my brother was there they knew that I'd
probably go AWOL on a Sunday uh just to
go and play games of league on a Sunday
yeah
um play play rugby said they try and
hitchhiking the bloody Hall today and to
Hastings and try and skip a game of
League but uh because my brother did
that before I got there yeah they kept a
close eye on me so I pretty much started
playing like properly when I got to
college I had probably two games before
that intermediate oh really far out oh
it was only because my couple of my
mates
I was like but I don't even know the
rules there's too many rules
and they're like no no all good I
remember the first game I played I tried
to stand up and play the ball
tried to play the bloody boy and I was
like ah I don't think I was supposed to
do that but they were looking at me
cracking up I was like no yes we did
they tell me so he didn't know any of
the Rose really you were you didn't
watch watch rugby didn't watch all
blacks or anything growing up no not at
all like obviously being in boarding
school I did learn a little bit about
um I'm rugby up there but yeah I was
even then I was can we turn the the
league on I don't know what rugby I
don't know what you need yeah
um but by the time I got to the to my
senior year you know I actually had a
bit more interest than trying to watch a
bit more
rugby
um
but yeah the only reason I started
playing this because
League man that's crazy you must seem
pretty good at League then like
I was all right
uh
I went and played in the like uh
rangatahi tournament maori's tournament
and got scouted there
um but I had already assigned a an
academy contract
um
to apart from before Wellington and the
hurricane so oh what age was that what
age did you sign your hurricanes went
straight from this intermediate he's
playing the pool for me
yeah I'm striking the ball back tonight
uh no I was I was uh 18. oh yeah when I
signed it so I obviously there's like
the secondary school tournaments like
hurricane schools and all that where you
can get looked at
um
and then you know you're playing those
tournaments where you play the southern
teams the two Auckland teams and
obviously the hurricane region so yeah
it was
got signed it uh 18 with an academy
contract I didn't think much of it at
the time yeah I was gonna say are you
well whatever yeah see what see what
happens uh from it but um
yeah once I mentioned to them that our
son I was a in an academy contract I was
like well good you should take me
because I wasn't getting paid sure you
know it was just to try I think it was
just to try and lock me in and keep me
in Wellington yeah
um
but uh yeah they were one guy was
chasing me uh
quite you know hard out
um and I just said look I I don't know
if I can do anything about it because of
this Academy stuff that I've I've signed
but if you want to come back three years
and three is five when I'm finished yes
sweet three-year Academy contract but
now yeah
yeah just do trainings early in the
morning and at night before bloody Club
were you always a half back in Union no
actually it was um
they just put me wherever really no
obviously first my first year colleges
has put me
um well we just had a crackle River yeah
just wanted I pretty much played the
whole back line even though I wasn't a
fast person I don't know why they put me
on the wing I wasn't that quick
back myself though but but
um
obviously with my background I tried to
see if I could go into the Midfield
truck hit it up a bit more yeah uh
wasn't as big and strong as bloody uh
some of the boys so they just put me on
a bit closer and I've just been playing
1910 since mostly 10. yeah when did you
start really honing in on your crafter
as a nine as a halfback uh probably when
I left left school oh really this
Academy 18 sort of yeah or just playing
playing Club really oh yeah I played I
played club for um hot old boys Marist
and um they were Premier teammate they
were the premier team or Club at the
time
but um
the goal was to try and help Elevate
them into the premiere
um league in Wellington
and um
I still remember like
even with some of the old boys in the
team always
that confident that I wanted to play
every
position I played second five eight in a
couple all in one game and their coach
after this yeah no we'll stick to
putting you at 10 or 90.
but um yeah I spent most of my time at
at 19. what did you prefer 10 because I
don't want to dig in uh into a rack
impossible did you get pulled back into
it sometimes there's bloody racks so you
wanted to play league and then you
wanted to play 10 but you somehow end up
being uh all black night
yeah probably wasn't the fastest either
bloody or the tallest bloody Jimmy Jimmy
was Bloody huge then he next to him or
Donald is like up here and I'm like way
down here and I'm like
lose some some of your height so I don't
look so bloody short
what's it like going into the Wellington
setup because how old were you when you
had your first
um you're first named in the Wellington
lions 20. man so it all happened pretty
fast I was 19 19 20 turning twenty so
yeah a year and a half sort of setup of
playing nine going to these Academy
sessions and you're in there
which was a stacked Wellington team too
at the time too oh yeah I was just
grateful that Kelly was on the team
spiny normally fatal Jonah had made a
few appearances I know you know
obviously the big guy was sick
um but you know just to have him yeah
um and the team was like I was just just
because you watched some of the clips of
him to what he's done and just put the
game on the on the map you know
um
just to have in their trainings and it
was me it was mean just to rub shoulders
of him but he was a pretty
pretty thick team I remember my feet I
was actually talked about this last
night I was at a um
had a sneaking engagement and with the
gun boots on uh yeah
it was civil contractor so I felt right
I was at home but
um I was just telling them you know
the we played against Alfred that was my
I was my first game for Wellington loans
and um
I was nervous and nimir was on the team
as well so the both of us were really
nervous as you know young nervous so we
we actually rang our mates and went to
town
went down to Courtney place to go to
time zone
yeah we spent
a good two maybe three hours just
playing freaking laser tag you know
playing games and things like that and
um
we went back to the hotel
and basically we didn't even feel
nervous after that it was like it was
almost like a uh
uh relaxation sort of sort of thing just
to get everything off us offer all the
news out of our out of our system
and it happened we did that quite a few
times in our first year
um and yeah looking back now I was
I remember when I mentioned that last
night Dale looked at me like ah did you
go around himself no no I didn't go out
I went out with my mates to go ties that
time zone so I can bloody game play
species
did you do that throughout your career
like before the World Cup or anything
like that when you were nervous did you
yeah so yeah your roots of times though
everything changed we started having
card games now oh yeah yeah it stopped
the bus
um I think kids call it three out three
down these days
presidents and uh you know [__]
all those games in like I remember
um
you know it started off with just a
a few of us and then it just started
getting bigger and better uh bigger and
then the boy started getting real
competitive
so it got to the stage where we had if
there was six of us playing and there
was we're always there'd always be a
waiting list
boys would be just sitting there waiting
to get in so as soon as he got knocked
out and whatever it was you're out next
person then
and you're just sitting there waiting
like hurry up man speed these games out
so I can have a chance to come back in
so yeah it went from bloody species to
um to cards oh how good and even like
when you'd made Wellington did you did
you love Union at this stage or were you
still like wishing to be a league player
um I was torn to the Beer League man but
I I was
um grateful that you know
I had
um worked hard enough to sort of uh get
a foot in the door yeah and then from
there I just had to learn obviously you
know she's a bit different uh when
you're just a kid Roy is just
out there sometimes you just don't cares
when they have a crack dummy try and run
through someone get smashed backwards
and you just keep trying until you
actually get through so
um it was I
I thoroughly enjoyed my first season
um you know I had the likes of spicy
um to learn off
um in terms of uh you know I guess
understanding the ins and outs of of a
nine
um and learning my craft through him but
not only that like at Club you know head
guys that um that helped me out
um and that I could rely on or lean on
if I if I needed a ham or something out
on the field
um and
yeah from I guess after the end of the
03 uh Wellington or the
um NPC comp and I actually got name
which was a shock I didn't think I was
good enough to actually be named in the
hurricane Squad uh in 2004 so
it was I to be fair I thought I didn't
think I'd done enough to to be um you
know considered to be selected in their
squad and uh and I didn't even think I I
am done enough to to be a part of the
whole campaign right but you obviously
had because you you were playing that
first year pretty much straight away
from Emery weren't you pretty much goal
kicking and everything oh a little bit
not not so much like um
the the beauty of it all was like
I spent some time with Ricky food he was
a senior when I was at TA Ricky Flutie
oh true okay so I used to have to be his
ball boy used to practice as kicks
during the week
and you must have known uh this little
punk will know how to kick so
he was kicking goals and I had the Buddy
kicked him back through him and stuff
like that so
it was um
good having uh flutes like a as as a
senior you know looked up to him at
um at school uh he made you know New
Zealand schools and and all that at the
time
and
you know just to have him at at the
canes as well
um you know just
it made things a lot easier for me to
sort of try and help myself out and get
into the team and
um see what I can do to or what I can
learn from the old heads and obviously
learn a bit more about the structures
and game plans and trying to stick to it
not try and do your own thing
yeah was it an intimidating team to go
into obviously heaps of Legends
um so I'm quite intimidating
faces as well
um no it was actually quite an uh
inviting yeah they might look ugly and
scary on the TV and on the on the field
but like you know they actually sort of
it it was the same when I made the the
All Blacks yeah it felt like I had been
in the team for like a couple years
already
um
yeah the hardest part it wasn't so much
meeting the boys and all the Legends and
you know
fan fanboying at some of them it was
more as soon as you meet your teammates
you had to go and do your testing
so obviously back then it was the old uh
3K time trials oh phosphate decrement
Sprints oh man I've never done all that
kind of stuff before yeah you know
wasn't wasn't one of my uh favorite
bloody tests to do and then uh I
remember trying to like we did uh bench
press squats and all that chin-ups
and they're not going to hardly pull
myself up on the chin uh on the chin
rack and bloody without making us push
uh push UH 60 kilos on the bench you
know I couldn't even push that by the
time I had like uh
finished my career I was actually I was
happy because I doubled my bloody bench
I was benching 120 so I was happy that I
actually uh got better at that
when you're doing the Hurricanes that's
your testing yeah it was the 3K and then
after we had to do like uh the phosphate
decrement which is like
uh 40 meter Sprints and it's 10 and all
timed and then you've got like you walk
I think you walk five meters come back
five meters and then count down and
you've just gotta like try and
stick to the same timing every time but
yeah honestly you look like you
absolutely love that yeah
I I loved it all right
they did have a pretty tough year from
memory that first year you're in there
but they did get better each year over
the next following year up into the sort
of fog final
um I know you're a big part of that game
what do you remember about that one ah
it was actually foggy I actually got
knocked down in there again oh did you
yeah I actually put my head in the wrong
place
I caught the knee from uh Kevin Senior I
went to try and make a tackle on him got
need was that cold
um
I'm sure I I think if you look back on
the footage you can just sort of
make it make out that someone's lying on
the ground
um
and I tried to I slowly come oh I
wouldn't say I Keen to but got up got
checked carried on and then I missed the
tackle against um Casey
um
even when I'm not foggy I probably would
have missed their tackle too but um
I didn't actually know what was
happening until about one o'clock in the
morning the next day I was I was out
with the team and my older brother was
there with me keeping an eye on me but
um
you know we're out and I I actually was
like looking around going hey
I was looking finished
the red mate where that's one o'clock in
the morning we've got to go far out so I
ended up I ended up going back to the
hotel and uh
basically you just went straight to
sleep because I didn't know what the
hell was going on and I just wanted to
make sure that everything was sweet when
I woke up
um earlier on that morning man that is
crazy the boys asked oh do you remember
the penalty kick that you did I was like
walking ready
and you did you play the whole game like
that yeah pretty much yeah I played the
whole game like that I suppose no one
could see that you were you were
struggling no I love you the our team
doctor and physio we're both on the
sideline the opposite side line where I
got where I got knocked out oh they
wouldn't have seen anything yeah the
coaches would have seen it no you can
never find the footage you're just out
there absolutely Batley
an autopilot and that was before the
sort of concussion protocols and all
that had come and it was it was still
pretty old school back then you shake
them off and you get back into it yeah
pretty much so I'm just grateful that
um that was the last game so I wasn't
trying to back up the week after yeah
um and try and figure out what the
bloody hour happened the week before
would you have um stayed out there now
knowing what you know now
um
I probably would yeah just because you
know
none of us ever want to go off the field
unless we've got a broken leg like you
got to drag us off the field in order to
get us off and I think I'm not saying
that's the attitude to have but back
then you never really you just wanted to
be on the field to go to war weekend
week out and
when when that number come up on the
sideline and you'll and it showed your
number you obviously you would have been
pissed off and stuff like that but yeah
you know I know with the protocols I
understand it as a coach now
um that you know you've got to take care
of
um your players
um whereas obviously you know they're
thoroughly checking
um boys everyone's that have taken the
head knock but you know are absolutely
fine yeah but
you know just to make sure that they
haven't had like a
delayed concussion of some sort or
anything like that but yeah if I now if
I was still running around I'd I'd still
be trying to run and stay out there as
much as possible yeah and you obviously
can't remember the game but do you
remember like walking out there that day
or like the whole fog situation playing
I remember going to the game uh on the
on the bus and how how foggy it wasn't
like surely surely we're all playing in
this surely it's gonna lift but
all I remember was the national anthems
yeah our national anthem and that was it
done I'm sorry but I do remember sort of
leading up to the game uh into the
national anthem
um after that everything's a blue right
I was in the stands that day I remember
driving down from Nelson to come watch
the mighty canes get their first ever
Victory couldn't see a thing absolutely
gutted oh exactly the worst part is you
try and do a box kick your boys are
chasing it but how they're going to see
the where the ball's coming
little lady I was looking at the Rica
because Riku was uh on the on the wings
you guys because I had no idea where
their ball was coming from you just had
to wait for the Sun as soon as you hear
the sun oh yes and they're pretty close
it's one of those games there you'll
always remember or you won't always
remember but even remember the whole
situation because it's just one of those
things where it was like so crazy so
bizarre oh I don't like I think for us
um we wish that we probably could have
um sort of you know continue to like
postpone the game and play another day
yeah just so that we could actually see
what we're doing and have a problem
Cricket you know double position that
way yeah you're flying that year to a it
wasn't too bad
and then obviously the following year
2007 Rugby World Cup rolls around
um you're in the All Blacks at the time
but you missed out on uh World Cup
selection what was that like to deal
with
oh
it was tough because
as soon as you get told it's like
they're pushing me out the door to get
the hell out of there that's right so
that the boys could the the next sport
is can come in without you know being
awkward
there's also the letter of us like the
back boners or the DD's they're weak
Tuesday nights is usually you know the
night for the DDS where we get to go out
and just you know have our night out
and so obviously there was
all this bloody rubbish around it has
been given to
um put on the Ted's bloody door about me
and a few of the other boys being out
uh and all that
um
two nights before a bloody uh a test
and so
when that
all started coming up after I was like
you can't get onto our floor
the only ones that can get onto our
floor are people that are actually
staying at the hotel and they've got to
be having I mean they've got to have a
key to get access to our floor
so clearly you guys are talking yards so
it kind of you know it kind of
um was a tough pull to swallow
I remember
once I got told
pack my bag as quick as I could
um
jobs in the vehicle that uh that took us
to the airport just as we did that the
other band showed up and I realized who
they picked over me
so Andy jumped out of the van and walked
in and obviously okay
so you went with him yeah all good true
so there's no conversation or anything
about what was happening you were just
told you're gone oh thank you pretty
much they tried to they tried to
sugarcoat it but
the way I saw it was all right sweet you
don't [__] want me all good yeah
um and then after that I went home
um and tried to figure out whether I
hang around or if I go to Aussie and
Tron
have a crack at my dream sure was that
legit you went back
um looking at League clubs oh no I
didn't look at any clubs but I I knew in
my head okay these guys don't want
there's a waste of time me staying
around if I'm not gonna if I didn't get
looked in right now to play In This
World Cup
then clearly I don't need to be here
um
and so
all I needed to do was just finish
because we still had MVC so all I needed
to do was finish my campaign with NPC
um once that's done then I was gonna I
was Keen to try and
um
said
don't see some clubs over in Aussie how
close did you get
ah I ended up my agent told me that I
had about three offers on the table
um but I had a I had a young some older
brother
um Billy and um
he said to me that I wasn't allowed to
go
like he said to me now you've got a
you've got
a job to do here you've got a point to
prove
yeah it might take four years it's going
to be four years of hard work you're
going to be in and out but you've got a
point to prove just to shut there shut
them up
because like there's the two contracts
there and like to me it wasn't like so
much about the the money it was more the
dream like what you loved yeah yeah and
so
for that to be sitting
you know you all had to do is say yeah
sign
and then my brother's like no you're
going nowhere you're gonna you've got
four years to work to get this right
that's crazy crazy how close everything
was hey sliding doors what where you'd
be now and how all your life would be
um if you did just say yes what what
clubs were they otherwise
no the door has been on the table I
think it was the Titans and the Bulldogs
oh that's true I've always I've been a
Broncos fan since they thought I
reckoned that they had to put one in
front of me I probably would have signed
up straight away yeah
man that's crazy but then obviously uh
your brothers words of wisdom did work
out because four years later you are
named in the um Rugby World Cup squad
what was it like because you'd come off
a pretty rough year with the hurricanes
too that year too
orcas we had
um I was still coming back from a broken
[__] I broke my leg and uh NPC oh
that's right that was a nasty one too
yeah I had a fracture dislocation the
old ankles out this way oh I I think you
know the best part was that the stroke I
think the stripping tape saved me
a longer recovery oh yeah like in terms
of like um you know if my ankle wasn't
strapped I reckon it would have been a
lot longer in terms of the recovery side
of it come off
um so it was a it was it was definitely
a struggle for me and you know
coming off that and then starting
training
I mean I'm I'm going to the gym by
myself
um it's stupid o'clock just to not be
anywhere near the team yeah but still to
get my job I get my my training and
um
and oh man I'm not gonna lie I was in
some Dark Places during during that time
just because I hate doing the same stuff
over and over like it felt like all the
trainings I was doing was very
repetitive
um and I'll try to explain it to my
trainers and I was just swearing at them
the whole time like I was uh yeah it's
probably not the best best guy yeah to
be be training at their time but um
my brother started coming along helping
me out pushing me through it
um not so much on the training side of
it he'll be sitting there acting like
he's on a machine trying to do cardio
but really he's looking at me like hurry
up me push the bloody uh the bloody uh
bar so that we can uh keep up with this
bloody recovery side of things so yeah
that was that was a tough period in time
for me like not being able to be doing
pre-season with the boys having the
field with the boys
um and so the day that I actually got to
run around
um on the field
I was like one of my happiest days
because I was I was getting closer and
closer
to joining the team again yeah
um
but yeah it was a it was a massive
battle in my head uh through those
periods of times and then when I finally
started playing rugby my biggest thing
was whether I was confident enough that
it wouldn't break again
and I know flashbacks of what happened
what are we getting those flashbacks
yeah so you know someone will tackle me
and I quickly jumped just to try not to
yeah record again and stuff like that
but you know
it took me a while I think
um
that whole process helped me realize
that you know
um when you're when you've got a injury
that's kept you out of the game for so
long you know you've actually got to
make sure that you look after yourself
properly yeah you know I mean
not not in the sense of like eating but
like in the sense of like actually doing
rehab actually stretching
um
doing some Mobility around around the
injuries so that you know it's not
stiffening up and that you still want
that flexibility that you had beforehand
um just little things like that so
you know
trying to move forward get myself into a
condition where I'm still
um able to play footy I'm not not quite
at my playing week but they're still you
know
having that process to get me to an
interview by
end of like try Nations yeah
um that was that was the process that we
had put in place with a the All Blacks
coaches uh and the trainers both the
hurricanes and also
um girly
um you know that that helped so much in
terms of you know okay if I actually
make sure that I I spend spend time
uh and stick to it
that I actually you know
um there to support me and they're
giving me the confidence that I need
that you know
if you get yourself from a good
condition and you can start playing
Super Rugby you know there's an
opportunity there for you but
you know you can't just sit back and
wait yeah and think that it's just gonna
be there you've still got to fight to to
earn that that opportunity to be in the
team again yeah did you think you could
do it obviously what you'd been through
with weren't packed and then going
through this the mental struggles and
training by yourself it's so isolating
did you did you feel like you're going
to be able to get back to the bit your
best and be available oh I just knew I
would definitely be available yeah like
uh just from conversations with uh the
three wise men you know they gave me I
wouldn't say reassurance
but they gave me an enough to make me
feel like yes if I actually put
um my head down and my ass up and go to
wink that
that's what that I've I've been fighting
for as potentially there but if you
don't work for it it's not going to be
then we're just you know
not going to bother with it but some
yeah
I guess the the biggest part was trying
to get on the field first and foremost
yeah um I managed to give back to
playing
a few games for for Winery
um that's where I was getting a bit
scared you know I mean it was wet too
and uh you're just thinking oh someone's
actually going to slide underneath me
it's gonna happen again and my dream of
you know playing in the World Cup is
going to be taken away from me once
again but um
yeah I slowly got a bit more confident
with it and then managed to come back
playing uh against the force wisdom
Force upon me
and um
the lungs were freaking screaming it
wasn't so much for the rest of their
body but the lungs were streaking me
like what are you up to cuz so
um it was yeah it was awesome just to
finally be able to get back on the field
uh you know and start playing footy with
the boys again
um
but yeah it was it was definitely tough
like all right I battle fruits on demons
yeah to uh to get there but you got
there and how'd you find out how did you
find out you were going to the 2000m
rugby workout I will because they had
obviously the steinlager series
um before try Nations
and then uh obviously the transitions
but because it was such a big year we
had
um
the earthquake down in Christchurch
so majority of the team
um
it was involved in the trial Nations uh
we played they played the games here in
New Zealand so when Kimberly boys played
um those games but we left to go to
South Africa
all the Canterbury boys stayed home to
be with their families oh yeah
um and so
we were not there
I wouldn't say we've uh under strength
team
but it was Now full full team but we
still felt
that we could do the job
um so we went there
um played South Africa lost to South
Africa and they actually named the squad
we were in South Africa oh yeah so all
the players knew before everyone else
knew
um when uh when they announced the team
but there's
distinct part about it was we had to go
to Brisbane after that everyone
everyone oh true so these guys knew and
they still had to play a game the boys
that didn't make the squad hit the
Trevor to
um Australia to Brisbane
and um you know basically they had no
chance to go home and be more whanau
um to to support them and be there for
them you know through that period of
time so a few of us decided you know
I've got no family here we're family we
feel like we're family to them so we
need to be around
be around them
um to make sure that they're you know
they know that we're here for you bro
you know it's a sad time
um
and so
we lost them
Brisbane
um and
you know for all of us we well it's the
first time we actually seen Ted for his
toys bro
well especially in the change rooms I've
never seen him for his toys that that
bad before
um
but the way I've seen it is those two
losses that we did that we that we had
in the trial Nations
uh to our nation's actually set us up
for uh the World Cup because
we understood that there's
three areas that we need to take care of
to help us
have a successful campaign obviously one
of them was the mental side of it that
was a huge one
we spent more time focusing on our
mental side of the game
the other one is the midship's been the
momentum shifts on the opposition side
and how do we get that back
and then obviously with
2007 they had no one taking them a shot
at the old uh drop kick yeah you know we
actually set ourselves up
um so that that was up our Our Sleeve
whenever we needed to pull it out
um so
leading into the World Cup I was
confident that we were going to win
because
I felt that we've focused on three eras
that we needed to
and we basically just tried to nail it
week in week out with those those three
things right it's it's positive news for
all all blacks fans heading into this
world cup too that I forgot that you
guys had lost two games going into that
World Cup I just remember you guys being
red hot favorites to win it
yo well to us we we obviously you know
being at home
um you know you want to make sure that
you get the job done but
I felt we we worked hard
uh in those three areas to allow us to
to get to the big dance and if we needed
to like set ourselves up to go go for
the win
we we've done everything possible to to
give us that chance
um if we needed to
but um yeah there was huge leanings for
us that's what I felt anyway not only
that those three things there we we've
done a lot of other things
um leading up to trainings
we had many many group chats so all the
nines and tens will get together yeah
and the the best things that we talked
about were the what-ifs what if we're
losing what do we do and like
all of us would have our our input the
rest of it was just yeah what he said
but do you try and throw a little
a little uh ripper in the uh in the
system and then the boy's looking
that helped us understand that like if
someone or in the team that's important
goes down
what do we do next and obviously
with DC
dcw's uh flixa training before Canada
um
you know we didn't actually panic
we knew exactly what we needed to do
because we talked about it we and uh
you know
that made us understand that like okay
he's gone down oh
you're going in you're doing the same
role you know whatever you need you need
uh help with when you got your back
um if he's not if he's not doing
something we'll talk to him about it you
know I need you to play a bit more down
here yeah um how many tens deep was it
till yeah um status I think okay we're
getting low here or putting your hand up
I know you love playing team no
I think um it didn't matter how many we
we had we we felt that like yeah yeah I
think you know with Aaron coming in and
getting injured Eva coming in you know
um
we basically told Beaver that week even
the same would have crud when he was
there Aaron we said look you just played
footy we got you you just we just want
you to you know if you need to put us in
the right end of the field you know
these are the columns so that everyone's
on the same page
um but we just want you to go out there
and play footy and we can run the team
if you want but if you want to run this
team with us
let's go and so it didn't matter who he
had I think
we had a redone homework and we put on
all the hours we needed to to to execute
a game plan so when
um whether we were
seven points down 12 points down
we still knew that we could execute the
game plan if we really needed to
um we probably shouldn't have you know
gave everyone a heart attack and
finished with eight seven in the final
but
um I think for us you know it wasn't
just a relief it was more the fact that
you know we
we practice everything that we wanted to
to execute
obviously we've seen it in the in the
Australian game and the semi we're
including that the dropping and we
talked about getting that whenever we
needed that and we could have executed
that in the final at some stage
um but not only that leading into
um Argentina
those momentum shifts we understood like
you know
we need to make sure that we're in
control if we start losing control
and there's a like a floral effect where
we're losing the momentum it's a drop
ball penalty lose a line out lose a
scrum you know we need to go back to
basics and figure out okay this is what
we've got to do now
everyone needs to calm down get
ourselves back into the now execute this
finish with that so we had a lot of
processes
um mapped out before we even got to to
World Cup which helped us
immensely to to get the job done yeah
and you obviously dead and how do you
feel about the whole movement of keep
calm pities on obviously started after
the seven from Seven
um penalties against Argentina in the
quarterfinal we're obviously Carter had
gone down needed a kick it a step up you
step out how are you feeling going into
that game being a goal kicker with
literally the country on your shoulder
oh
I don't know I'm probably a bit
different to this lady and also the
Dizzy
um you know
with kicking you either get it or you
don't
know
[__] happens you just got to get on with
it and play footy
um
I guess I was just lucky that you know
uh
the practice that I had done which was
none during the week like oh
I don't I never practice my kicks
because I I loot through
um Nick Boone yeah the if the ball flies
flies in a certain way
um that's not my natural flight then
I've done something
um wrong in it and I need to figure out
what it is so I figured out what a
perfect perfect kick looked like for me
and felt like and then anything after
that if it didn't feel like that I don't
I had done something wrong so
um
come quite a final time I don't practice
kicking kicking that week I only
practice in the warm-up that's crazy I
got the more warm up
um practice my kicks and just all I was
looking for was just if I was on the
right hand side
how the ball was flying yeah
um and if there was any wind there you
know how hard it was pushing it across
the post yeah go the left-hand side get
a feel of the exact same thing sort of
little bit to the sides and see what you
know what I've got to do as long as I'm
sticking to my process and just kicking
through rather than because I know
sometimes when it's an easy kick you
know some kickers just actually think
I'll just tap this over yeah but if you
don't follow through with your whole
process you know it's um it can actually
jeopardize the float of everything yeah
so
just trying to get a feel of it and then
went on like then maybe one or two on
the on the 40 just to see you know the
further out if it flies differently
um when I'm trying to kick through it
um but yeah that's
that's all down to to make Boone about
you know teaching us the mechanic more
teaching me the mechanics of kitty
whether it's box kicking
um ticking out of the hand
um Place kicking drop kicks you know
learning everything through him who's
the next AFL player yeah you know some
of the skills that he he taught or
something are you sure you didn't play
legal rugby Cubs because like I don't
think I've seen any of these bloody uh
drills or these skills by anyone else
and you're an ANF AFL plan
so you know this is like to me I was
mind-blown that someone or a legend of
the AFL
comes and he's a kicking coach for us
but not anything he's like teaching us
all about like punching the ball
you know rather than trying to reload
and things like that so yeah
all the all the mechanics of like
kicking through milk you know I I
wouldn't say I didn't have to break this
well like if anything I needed to keep
practicing was around my general play
kicking box kicking my goal kicking I
didn't need to practice that because
are pretty much understood right you
make it sound so easy
oh it is once you understand like it's
yeah it's it's bizarre let me know
watch Jimmy gobert a few times at Rigby
League parking
you know Jimmy's a great kick and just
the battles he was having with himself
yeah you know just swearing at the ball
like
for the goal post and I'm like
um
why are you getting angry at that like
yeah you shouldn't be practicing because
you come to game day and you start you
know kicking exactly how you read
training that's just going to eat into
your
mindset or your uh think oh my God I
must have wonder why did I miss that one
oh my gosh I need to move on but you
know and so I used to that watching him
do that a few times I I'm just like you
know what not
I need to come up with something because
I don't want to have that where I'm
thinking too much about kicking in a war
between juice two bloody stuffs yeah you
obviously passed it on to him though
he's one of the most successful kickers
in the Premiership history
oh nah Jimmy's bloody he's always been
pretty hard at when it comes to like
kicking in general yeah he put a lot of
time into it so but um yeah
he's 40 this year yeah still going
strong yeah he's still running around
and uh in front incredible eh living the
dream wow
surprised he hasn't uh pulled out the
old golf clubs yet oh actually I think
he'll might have seen him pull it out a
bit cold over there to do surfing though
yeah especially in the winter yeah for
sure well what a what a World Cup and um
obviously once he'd won it the final
um beavers I think why were you kicking
that you'd missed a couple that game and
came off injured wow
another one what was with the groins
what's this kicking
wow after the quarterfinal
um
I actually done extra practice
no yeah I know but there's a reason why
though
like smoothie gave me this look of like
well you better be taking this buddy
seriously
leave you on the bench it'll get someone
else to do this that may take this
seriously but um
like yeah I was he gave me as soon as he
gave me the look I knew that look
straight away oh man yeah just let me do
my thing like don't
put pressure on me to practice
um and so I done a kicking fish in the
day before the semi-final
um
and
and shanked a few
kicked a few and then
did the same thing the week after I knew
it was a bit tight but just thought you
know
we'll get through the week
got to Captain's Runners look giving me
the look again I'm like
you really want me to so I practice um
at Captain's run
and then started warming up in the final
and going through my routine and
um
I think I've already been learning about
kick number four in my uh
and my kicking routine and
I just looked at Mick and was like bro
somebody's not feeling right here
because I keep pulling it to the left
it's because I couldn't I wasn't feeling
comfortable in my follow-through that's
right
um and so I basically told the physios
we went inside of what the hell they
were going to do to try and save me to
play
um
but yeah I um I tweaked my groin
and um
the two kicks that are like Woody's try
and the penalty that I missed both times
I was trying to figure out you know just
kick through like if I don't know their
gum Shield son and freaking hope for the
best but just as you go to approach you
know that back swing and then the
followers coming through you've felt it
as soon as you gladly planted you
thought you're like oh this isn't going
to be nice so you just pull out just
because you don't wanna
so that's the reason why I didn't kick
so well in that final and um even at
half time I ran to make I said no Beaver
needs to kick bro like um I cannot be
freaking kick yeah run around
um so it's crazy
so um we got together
and we him and I basically said to me
but look you've got a kick button you
all Goods the kid goals and people like
yeah
um and so yeah
Beaver stepped up and slaughtered now
there's a movie on him he actually uh
when he kept it I knew it went straight
between the sticks but um
Richie was telling you that he thought
he missed it
and baby was confident it's not not
working too early
remember running back too and I'm like
looking at people like Bruce what you're
doing
pulling it down all the time
oh so good I saw good memories of the
world cap one thing I do want to talk to
you about though is your obviously
hurricanes time it was I think it was
the same year 2011
um you leave the Hurricanes Keen to hear
around the conversations around that
because obviously hurricane Legend
um what happened there oh
to why we had our obviously a new coach
and
um
obviously all the all the leaders uh on
themselves
a massive influence on it but like
you're in the leadership group kind of
but not sort of hard out like Orion and
code but um because I'd obviously been
there since 04 and yeah and I've
obviously been
been around for quite some time
um yeah got together
with uh the head coach and you know
just basically said look
don't try and turn this into the
Crusaders because we're not you know
bring some of the
so like keep the fear that we've got but
you know there definitely is some areas
that we need to work on and if you could
bring that
um and give us the edge
around it I think you know everything
should be sweet
but obviously you know it's a little bit
like uh
Uncle Jamie Jo as well the highway type
type old school mentality yeah
um
and dude
sort of
a few boys buttered heads with him
because you know what we're trying to do
is
continue with what would have been
um doing but we understood the areas
that needed to change and to try and
turn us into a team that we're not
um rather than just working with the
kettle that you've got and understanding
the cattle that you've got
um and and nurturing that and trying to
make it
a little bit better give it a bit more
Edge to it and make sure that you
understand the errors that have
that uh aren't so great within the team
structure
um you know what it was a tough one all
my mates all the senior boys are pretty
much getting pushed out
um
and I had a chance to sort of stay or go
and I read an article him saying that uh
I left for to go to the blues because of
the money Brian was getting I got
offered more to standard hurricanes oh
really it had nothing to do with with
money
mine was more environment in terms of
like
you know
creating keeping the same sort of
um
culture that we've had
but not try and
change it too much you know I still want
to keep that
structure that we've always had there's
as the hurricanes
you know predict unpredictable I think
it is or something like that yeah you
know trying to continue to keep that but
still have
um something that other teams
uh haven't seen us do which was
obviously the biggest one was the
breakdown being absolute ministers in
the Britain that's what the Crusaders
have been
dominant over the years there's all the
ugly hard work that those boys you know
like especially their pack no matter
what pack they had they had a pack that
would always
guys knew what their roles were if your
role was to hit rocks you hit rocks and
you're you're the you're obesity hitting
rocks you know
um we're probably left a little bit and
just relied on a couple of boys to do
those today's roles when in fact
everyone needed to roll the old sleeves
up and go to Mahi but um yeah it had
nothing to do with money mom was more
um culture and
the way that I I saw it wasn't wasn't
quite the culture that I wanted to be
involved with because it was changing
dramatically
um so
yeah that's why I decided to
um move away and and go to to Auckland
um and it was a tough one because you
know I didn't really want to leave
pressure from some of the boys to get
you to stay were they were some of them
saying come now please like stay and
some obviously who had left was there
pressure on them for you to leave as
well like we sort of stuck in the middle
a little bit uh I wouldn't sell the
stuff in the middle what I think like
body rang me
out of the blue tour and I was like hey
whose number is this you know obviously
I don't know that the young fellow yeah
I don't know the young followers you
know coming down and I was just like oh
yeah yeah
um
I'm gonna think about this one uh bro
but you know obviously the lights are TJ
was coming through
um and in terms of uh you know wanting
to
um continue uh been a dominant force
that he has been
um you know had a jgp he's now with um
with Ireland
Jameson Gibson Park you know he was
looking at my heels
um and so I thought you know what I'll
be Keen to try a different culture and
see what we can what I can achieve with
it wasn't the greatest in 2010 uh 12
sorry but um definitely some some big
improvements after that from uh moving
forward in 2013 and that so
the biggest reason was I could see that
the the culture and the
way that they were moving wasn't quite
uh the one that I was thinking it would
be so I thought I'd
you know have a bit of a change and see
what it was like yeah and how'd you find
the culture up there in Auckland
different
are you the big [__] lots of Auckland
the Big Smoke
um
we we had a coffee machine in a barista
but I'm like well this is the next level
just to have a coffee and you're bloody
uh yeah just go to the cafe and get one
come
um but yeah just just things like that
but other than that like
um
lending my who my new teammates are even
though we played against them yeah
played side by side with some of them
um
and I just seen it as a opportunities
just to try and start fresh
um
it wasn't easy though
like obviously every season everyone's
slagging me around the media around my
weight and stuff like that so
in the 2011
um I almost lost my father and so
rather than me training I was at the
hospital we were sleeping on the floor
just so that we could be next to Dad who
was in ICU and um
like a I got I come close to not going
to Auckland
because I wanted a video for my dad yeah
um just in case you know if anything
happened I was there
um
and so
definitely wasn't had no desire to train
um all I wanted to do was just yeah be
there so I just sat there waiting
sometimes we're doing anything we're
just sitting there waiting
um helping out the nurses and stuff like
that to help roll out there to
um basically you know
tidy him up and make sure he's nice and
freshly
um that he's not sort of like I think
they give
because uh in the Comas and stuff like
that sometimes they get um sores and
things like that yeah so we tried to
make sure that we helped him out because
he wasn't
wasn't the skinniest man to
to
um bloody lift as a as it is so our
family was always there trying to help
out when we could
um
and uh
so when I did finally moved to Auckland
and I wasn't
uh and great Nick
but um I always knew that like if
there's a if there's a goal that you
want me to get to I'll bust my ass to
get get to it yeah so there was always a
um a big goal a medium gold when it
comes to trying to drop the weight
um just so I could be running around
with the boys
um
but it was a
a lot of things happened in the
background with the in a few season up
there
um
but other than I enjoyed my time in my
first year uh at the blues and then also
with Auckland
um in the second year obviously with JK
had just been announced his army head
coach
um at the blues and
uh I didn't think we we didn't lose too
many players from the the year before so
you know it was
a rebuilding phase
and slowly sort of
understanding of the young Talent there
was coming through and how how much
potential and talent they had
the likes of like
Frank halai George Moana Charles pierto
Peterson
you know yeah
those boys kids coming into our
environment or environment like that
um
you know
so my hat started changing after that in
terms of okay if I'm going to be a
leader and have these kids come through
I need to be in better shoot so 2013 I
was
in pretty good like close to I was
pretty much near my plane weight
um
you know and it was the first time I had
a pre-season Cherry a full price yeah in
a long time the old preseason so I loved
it oh
okay
I missed there's a couple of sessions
that I missed sand dunes was one of them
I wasn't there yeah
very technical
but I mean like
in terms of
um
the rebuild you know yeah trying to help
nature those boys and get them to
understand yeah
the weird thing about footy now
everyone's talking about rugby diet and
there's a massive reason why it's
because these I wouldn't say it's just
because of the Auckland Auckland schools
but
these kids are getting skeleton very at
college
and then they go from college and going
straight in straight into a professional
environment but they don't know how to
play footy
yeah I've gone I haven't played one
season in Grassroots rugby at Club level
where I live my craft through all the
old heads the 100 Capers the 200 cappers
um out from the club listen to the
stories in the coming from all the old
timers about their days in the in the
jersey and it's just like you know these
kids go to school and go straight into
professional environment they haven't
learned the art of actually playing
footy and especially in their in their
role as a nine or ten or even a prop
you know so
yeah ask a point trying to trying to
help them out coming from college
straight into
um Super Rugby yeah and even NBC you
know you're just trying to
give them as much advice as possible
around you know seeing different
pictures and understanding what pictures
look like shapes that people present so
that you can turn them inside out break
the ankles
um you know just just little little cues
like that to help them understand
um rather than because I have a feeling
some of these kids these days like
because they've been taught
throughout the career this is how you do
this this is the net make it all the way
to professional
and then they're like
there's no Instinct they don't know how
to play a heads up heads up footing like
there's opportunities to play
uh like behind the Pod and then you
shift it to an inch but they're just you
carry you carry and then then they're
standing there waiting so when are we
gonna have a go yeah you know that's I
find watching some of some of the footy
a bit you know a little bit of a robotic
oh massively and you you were such an
instinctive player yourself as well you
played a lot of feel and you're just
like a natural baller when you must see
these guys who like you say so
structured now at such a young age that
they're not looking for the space
they're just sort of looking for their
own team shape not what's actually in
front of them oh exactly but I think
probably back then when I was a kid
coming up you know I played every sport
there was yeah you get to college and
are pretty much telling you no you can
only play rugby
you can't play basketball you can't go
play volleyball
um just in case you get injured I'm like
right if you want to go and play any
other sport at the same time and you
don't get injured right I'm all for it
yeah you've got to learn how to how to
read scenario is different so you
transfer that from one game into another
okay
I saw him do that oh actually I can see
him do that show me a different picture
too you know how much of that did you do
in your um rugby career how much league
did you sneak off and play I've heard
rumors that used to sneak off the odds
Sunday and play even when you're at the
canes and All Blacks Etc oh those are my
early days oh it was the days when I
yeah
um I used to put a headgear on and try
and hide here's my middle name yeah
encouraged by my father sometimes too
um but I would never play sort of
Premiere I'd always gameplay oh yeah and
just carve up oh no just I just wanted
to be sort of out there and you know I
found the development with it because
they presented pictures there
um a different to some of the
um pictures you see in the Rugby field
yeah
um with body shape and body language of
individuals
and you know with League
some some of those some of them is
Defenders aren't great Defenders when
when you've got to move them when
they're lateral they're not used to it
because they're all used to you running
straight at them yeah um and then that's
why you see so much mass effects because
you know they're trying to actually run
for a brick wall and they're getting
absolutely folded
um
but then when you actually see some of
the forwards you know start into ball
playing throwing a frontal back door
putting their own teammates into space
and
um you know then you've got fours
running good Hub
um lines to to the whole Defenders or if
they don't if they don't bite then
you're just putting them into wholesale
all that kind of stuff I thoroughly
enjoyed it yeah
coaching coaching my daughter's League
team
oh that's good seven one thing that
happened at the blues I think it
happened at the blues but did you have a
stroke at the blues yeah I did talk me
through that like that's pretty unusual
situation for a professional footy
player like obviously must have shocked
you
yeah so
we were recovery
um
and uh I was in the pool doing a few
lengths it was me
Peter sayley I think it was George
Moeller and Charles Peterson and we'll
obviously recovery do all your lands
you're swimming you're walking you're
stretching
and
we were just doing walking up and down
down the bordering our lints and
all of a sudden like
a good conversation over this you know
ask me a question I'm like yeah
What's Happening Here did I just
Mumble something and not open my mouth
but in my head I thought
yo this is um
this is what I hit so I was actually
yeah so I was like kind of just they
went talking like a baby
but you didn't know you were talking
like a baby no well I I did but in my
head I thought I was you know I knew
what I was saying yeah so I got
frustrated
jumped out of the pool got changed and
then walk went to walk out and uh Benji
was trying to get my attention because
he wanted my goggles
and like he was literally here and then
I was like oh were you trying to get my
attention yes so okay what do you want
your goggles on
my bed so I walked out still fresh and
jumped in the car and I sat there and
I'm like
what is going on here
um so I started at the car
I drove 50 meters
because my vision was getting blurry
I know my head I'm thinking wait what's
what's going on inside I was rubbing my
eyes squinting like a
what's going on here I'm just grateful
that I was like about three K's up the
road 4k's up the road to my house
drove slowly got home safely
and then went inside and just sat in I
was trying to I remember trying to fix
our team doctor to see help
um and I couldn't even text him
so I ended up doing the old uh
I thought you know what maybe I just
need to have a nap so I said I tried to
set my alarm
clearly wasn't functional so I was just
like oh
you know whatever so
he had a had a bit of a sleep
or wake up
had a little bit of uh Speech To Me
and asked my cousin to take me to the
team doctor I need to go and see the
team doctor
um
she drove me there he wasn't there so I
gave her my phone and said Frank ring
the doctor
um we were actually traveling to South
Africa that afternoon
and so I had to pack my bag and um
ended up sort of panicking a bit like
hey what what the hell is going on did
you have any idea what it could be what
no what I thought it might have been
the Lincoln cushion from um the game
you've been like before yeah because I
remember
getting a bit of a
kid Clash of uh I don't know if it was
red or or fliny but
um
I just thought okay maybe maybe it was
it and that's like super delayed but
um
I remember going to our team doctors uh
um house
um and he was talking about uh you know
he said the Lincoln cushion too
um maybe
dehydration of being
I didn't do anything last month so how
can I be dehydrated or I peeled back a
couple of those parades and you know
let me run into the photo after that
massive dehydration sometimes
and then his last one he said
um stroke
under my head I was like
are you serious no thinking this
potentially could be a stroke
um
well anyway we jumped on the planes of
South Africa went to Aussie flew to
South Africa
um
got to our team training while our first
team training the next day and I started
feeling real pale like even he was he
looked at me I was like oh [__] you're
like
white hairs sure I'm thinking hey tried
to sit down
and sort out training for the rest of
the day
um
and I noticed that like I was struggling
to
retained
our team patterns that week
like in Miami I know this is like being
brilliant butter for me why am I
struggling to understand what's going on
here
and so yeah it was it was bizarre
we were away for two weeks come home and
I knew something was up so I asked if we
could go and get some scans done
and um
yeah we we got a few scans done done a
few tests and found out that there was a
hole in my eye all right you obviously
didn't play while you're away we just no
I played a couple games you played with
it yeah is that dangerous or not
how would I do
I'm assuming if you
yeah if you do you know what it is right
from the get-go year yeah definitely but
if you have no
no
um understanding of it being an actual
stroke at the time
just to continue and go back yeah we
were playing
we come home and I was like no man I
said to the dog
we're gonna get some tests
something's plan plan up
honestly have no idea but I know there's
something wrong with me so yeah
had a couple of scans done a couple of
tests and found that there's a hole in
my heart everyone's born with it
but no one knows whether it's closed or
not
see so they did this bubble test
um where they put I don't know if it's
dye or something but
they can
um scan the ticket at the same time and
if there's bubbles that go on the other
side of the heart that's how they find
out whether you've got a hole and if
you're always going to close the look oh
how
but the procedure
to to close the hole
was like
for five minutes
they literally put a slit in my main
artery in my head
put a
a line all the way up to the old takeout
and basically got to the position that
they needed to put this little cufflink
so to speak the way the heath Lane is
like a cuffling
put it one side out open it up pull it
tied up against the where the hole is
make sure it's sitting right and then
they push at the other part of the
cufflink twist it off and then pull the
done good to go yeah but I was honestly
I was lying on the table just looking at
it you can see this
oh you're awake I was awake bro oh yeah
I know exactly
he's already made the slip and you just
you're looking at these monitor the way
you're lying down like this feeling
oh man look at that that's pretty cool
looking at this going all the way to my
heart
and I go oh
are you doing that are you oh my gosh
was it a massive ticker
nah
honestly it was freaky but then after
that he once he unclipped it all at the
end and then just pulled the other thing
soda back up and I was gone far out man
that is crazy hold on I'm sorry and then
you're good like no issues after that
like
no I haven't straight back into it I had
uh two weeks after that two or three
weeks and then I was able to get back
out on the field
recovery
straight away how long is the recovery I
don't want to be out for the rest of the
season because and then you sign over in
the UK so what's London Welsh wasn't it
initially yeah
what was the reason behind that one
um
I actually wanted to get an experience
uh what the footy was like over that
side of the wheel oh yeah
um see what the Premiership was like
London Welsh were in the Premiership at
the time they just got promoted yeah oh
okay
um but I played in the weird world teams
comp
um and the coach was there so London
Welsh was there and um
I had a year into the coach and he
wanted to know how how the old ticket
was yeah no but that's all good
and then um
yeah he got in contact with my my agent
and
um we just kept in in contact until
I guess it was time for me to
put pen to paper and and see what it was
going to be like so it was yeah it was a
a new sort of experience obviously they
love their their forwards over there in
terms of
yeah playing instinctively like that's
your it's your game or not so much over
there especially back then yeah exactly
you've if you don't have a good pack
that's sort of you know to be dominant
inset piece in the field
um you know it makes things a lot a lot
harder but some weird some some Legends
in our team that's uh you know
um play for England you know Tommy May
oiley Barkley you know just a couple of
the boys to to name him
breathing in a couple of Russian
Internationals so it was you know
um
I was at RIT
you know but just she was a bit of a bit
of a drive to get to our home games it's
all down to Oxford from Richmond so that
was a new experience but um my time has
been here was was awesome I I just
enjoyed the whole
um um Journey
um you know I was still
bloody
doing the actions of a couple of the
couple of the boys there that have
played Super Rugby
um that moved over there like my
flatmate
I was locking McCaffrey who played
um for the brown bees oh that's right so
he he made up well he actually made
contact with me to see if I was Keen to
to be on flatmates and he was already
this on the Hebrew find us ahead and
yeah so it was good made some made some
good mates over there
um
yeah it was it was a totally different
competition that I'm used to um
I think I still would have preferred
Super Rugby just in terms of just the
constant battles that you have trying to
play chess and you know if you don't get
get it right and you
put too much of your bloody uh your big
guns in there you're gonna lose your
game but um over there
you're just Smash and Bash and make sure
that you can last for 80 minutes and if
your your team's not up to it you just
think it found out yeah and you went
through four clubs and pretty quick
succession to a like I think all those
contracts were terminated so by your by
you I think so what was the sort of
reason behal hey we're just not enjoying
it or no I got actually loned up to um
to wasps did you get loan from London
Welsh to wasps yeah it was a week a real
weird one because I don't want to to go
because you know I my biggest thing was
I got asked to go play for London Welsh
and I wanted to stay there with the
coach yeah
um just because he brought me over and
things like that but
he was like nah you should go
like look at her again because they're
worth us together
you're telling me to go
showed somebody uh wasps so I played uh
uh a handful of games for wasps and um
there was definitely totally different
to to London Welsh
in terms of the setup and stuff like
that but
you know
where they obviously brought all the
owner at the time
brought the State stadium out in
Coventry yeah and had all these massive
ideas and I was thinking wow was he
really that loaded obviously not
yeah I think you might have just got a
bit Trigger Happy on the on the market
but yeah it was sort of
uh eye opener after the season finish I
went went straight back to hang out with
the London well Welsh scores yeah I
didn't really want to go to watch I only
went there just because you know the
coach said that it would be a good
opportunity for me so we're from uh
not the worst to wolves and then got an
opportunity to get a go play in fronts
and uh we don't know that's one of the
ones I was trying to it's a hard one I
know you read it and you're like wow
this could be pronounced so many
different ways yeah oh yeah next is
usually one of them yeah I would have
definitely said that X and what was the
other one
um
so how'd you find it in France love the
lifestyle the lifestyle was awesome
um and just the French culture yeah
wasn't a massive fan of the the footy
well not the footy was fine I think it
was more the mentality yeah
you know they they do
um
like your character
for my short period of time there you're
guaranteed to win home games
and then you see in the academy team of
a couple Internationals to their away
games and you pretty much get slept
and I I I I just couldn't quite
understand it that you
we've been
I wouldn't say talk but we've been
driven to be uh winners week and week up
not one one week
celebrate one week go back to me winners
again you just want to be competitive
week in week out and so that whole
mentality for me was like it was a
bizarre I just
I couldn't understand it and
you know some of the standards there
weren't went High yeah and I'm like I
remember one training session I just
I had enough
that the boys just thought it was a joke
you know they couldn't even string a
couple phases together
and we just continue to and it was like
oh what did you do I just walked off I
did yeah yeah well
it's like you're trying to continue with
something that
that's just not going to be going to be
good so I just walked off just needed to
sort of like
have a bit of a breath take a break and
then go and now we'll agent I ended up
walking back out okay but I was sort of
just I needed you're straight on the
plane but uh no no no no no no no no I
just because I wanted to be you know a
leader there to help the club you know
to be successful but when
you're trying to be successful in the
team's standards aren't at a higher
level you're not going to reach the
potential to hit
um
that you should so for me it was you
know if we can have our standards High
here
and try and maintain that throughout the
course of the our campaign of our season
you know
we should be able to compete week and
week up but
when your standards are here on home
games and away games they're down here
you know it's just not a
it just didn't sit well that's all
I lost the love for the game yeah
just because of all that kind of stuff I
don't think it mattered when I was in a
a uh you know a top team or not
because I
you look at the competition and all the
top teams won home games and they target
some of the teams that are sitting at
the bottom of the term yeah because
those are the ones that they actually
need to win
just so that they can stay in the top
six yeah so to speak and then you know
they've done their job so so is that why
you move back to what upper bush
to get some love for the game back
oh I should just moved home and
just must have been real funny yeah well
so you're pretty much in your mind had
you finished playing footy pretty much
oh really okay
um it was just my cousin my cousin
keeping me
because well I was training with my
cousin Damon yeah and um he was just
like no I mean I'm training at the
trainer for the Bush come you should
come and play for them
and I was like
nah I'm all good it's like talking about
just training like I was training four
times a week with him obviously heading
up no bloody job
I don't know what what I wanted to do
next and um
I just yeah I buckled
and
decided okay well
I might need to lose a few kilos uh to
to actually start playing again and um
went over the or actually the the
coaching staff all came over to meet me
and you know basically
thing now [__] what do you want
I said well I'm not here for the
freaking money cuz
otherwise I wouldn't have said yes
um but what I do want is a vehicle of uh
petrol vouchers so that because it was
about four or five of us that were
traveling over oh yeah
yeah I said as long as we can get a
vehicle to go backwards and forwards
um and then the tank Suite then that's
all I want
um they did give us match fees and stuff
like that but I said look I'm not here
for the money you can either keep that
money or give it to her
um to a charity of your guys uh Choice
um and I just want to play footy
very I swear the first two sessions I
started like
oh my God this is why I love
the game really yeah
like those boys over that side farmers
tradies
they're up early hours of the morning
grinding away on the farms and you know
whatever trade that they're in
come to 48th night still got so much
energy
and then around you know hardly getting
paid for whatever that you know for for
showing up and I just love footy yeah
and
those first two sessions
watching you watching the boys I was
just like yo you know what
yeah I'll play
and then I just by the end of the season
I
totally fell in love with footy again
and felt that that's the right time
thing at the boots so
yeah even though it didn't play the last
game
um through injury but
you know just to actually fall in love
with the game again was was huge for me
and it was a sign that you know maybe
another time to to close that chapter
what a cool way to do it and you spoke
about injury like how was your body now
are you is your body sweat
oh
you know
that I've got arthritis in both my
ankles so like I sometimes I can hardly
run around I've been trying to run
around with my first 15 Boys in training
um and like yeah just can hardly move
um my right knee is bone on bone so
when it's a cold morning she's uh she's
slow uh to get up and get moving so
um but other than that like everything
else is fine but especially other than
my knees and ankles the man wants to
help you uh move from A to B trying to
Bloody Run Run races with your kids and
thinking that you still got it and then
they run past you like no that's it
we're going to be oh we'll have another
race soon not right now but we'll look
out yeah
so how hard did you find that transition
obviously you picked up your TV show
we've spoken about that but the
transition to go from not playing to
finding that new identity oh bro it was
tough like I'm not gonna lie it was
tough
I was at home doing nothing
um sleep most of the day like what the
hell are you up to bro
um
and then obviously got the opportunity
to
um
be the presenter for my TV series
um not only that I picked up a few gigs
for commentating yeah as well
um and it wasn't until
possibly this year actually that um
you know I've actually got my first real
job well my first real job
I'm actually I'm into it
um Wellington College
um helping out the meant to be no more
insurance but the way I see it is you
know on the air if I'm the only for all
those students if they need someone to
talk to
um you know my doors or if I'm in my
office you know a few other boys start
coming in now because they've got
uncomfortable with me so oh all good if
I just chill out in here have you got
class no or the yucky but
um I've been enjoying that
um even like earlier this year when I
first started my role at the at the
college
and I had to shoot off the go and do
filming
um
I was like can we speed this up
like I'm kind of missing my job
you know it was actually some like I
actually had a purpose yeah you know
when you when you go from rugby where
um you've got that throughout your
career but you know you
you're actually working on your craft
and then once the boots uh and the
lights are more that are gone you've got
to try and figure out you know what's
your previous in life after that
what's something that you're going to
love doing
um you know and that you're gonna enjoy
doing on a daily day basis basis like I
said this at a speaking engagement last
night that you know
after footy I don't want to be going to
someone's work and ruining their
business yeah because I'm not not sort
of invested in it I don't love it
you know if I'm going to do something I
want to be it's a drug that I love doing
that uh I'm driven to to help be
successful whether it's me or the people
that are around me to be successful
um you know things like that as opposed
to
rocking up in the morning
[__] attitude yeah yeah I don't want to
be here bro I'm just gonna be an [__]
today yeah so with my role that I have
now I mean honestly I'm absolutely
loving it of um you know trying to help
Mentor groups of of students individuals
and
you know trying to help them
it's weird because
year 13 students get to leave you have
to leave the school ground so you're
trying to help them prepare for yeah
yeah the big big bad world you know and
it's like well funny
um just finish that and I'm just fine
you found me
something to do together
so come on let me try and help you
figure this all out you know I mean
school's not for everyone
um
but you know the students that are there
you know you want to try and help
give them opportunities and
um you know try and constantly check up
on them to make sure that they've still
got their plan they're still working to
to execute it
um
so yeah it's been this year's been been
awesome in terms of uh you know nailing
a job
um and loving it as well and yeah you
know all the stuff that I'm working with
at Wellington College have been awesome
we've got a uh I mean our headbusters
awesome
um Glenn Denham he used to um be at
Massey he's a ex captain of tour blacks
so if you need someone to to actually
get the team up
he's not sure of a few good words and uh
inspirational uh chats
um so you know it's the way that he sort
of speaks as well it's it's
like
infectious because he's he's actually
caring about trying to get these kids
set up so that when they walk out the
gates for the last time
you know I've got a plan in place to
help them success be successful in life
sorry yeah it's honestly it's been
freaking been an awesome year um being a
mentor at the school and
you know trying to be organized and help
things out there and on top of that
coach the many codes of sports
on the way
mate sounds like all good stuff and no
doubt Wellington College around good
hands after listening to you here man
you'd be absolute perfect Mentor for any
young kid going through school but as
always we have gone to our Instagram for
some questions conscious of the time we
had thousands come in I'll narrow it
down to sort of the top three or four uh
first question was
um what did his props do to him when he
was the Hurricanes under 18 captain Oh
that's John shorter I know that for a
fact
I'm sorry
we're at uh was it Linton army camp I
think in Palmerston North and um we got
together as a
as a squad
um and uh
he knew that I was a Wellington boy but
because I went to Toyota played for
Hawke's Bay yeah
um
he said to me nah your Hawks pay I was
like
shut up you know exactly uh where I'm
from I'm all Wellington boy so
basically they got me into a room there
was about seven of the Wellington Boys
in there Anthony piranis was in there
too and I was like okay so they
basically said to me number one or
number two in my head I'm thinking are
we going to toilet Hill you know
but uh there was definitely no uh
bathroom in the in the in the room there
but um they said no I said well what's
number one they said well you can fight
your way out of this I said what's
number two and they said we'll strip you
to that to that chair right over there
and you could you can stay there
I was like
oh well looks like it's going to be
number one had a couple of props in my
team that were in their bloody room so I
knew I was going to be screwed no matter
what and um
so they basically strapped me to the to
the chair
and uh lift me therefore but
and um it was funny because
they did the exact same thing to Glenn
wooden oh yeah and all the hordes
basically said number two right from the
get-go he didn't even try and put up a
fight
I'm still I still give him a [__] about
that so that's what happened uh we were
in Camp being the captain you would have
thought surely I get a pass a bit more
respect eh okay no that wasn't to be it
wasn't to be oh cracker okay next one
what's the inspiration behind the two
blonde patches in your hair was it two I
always only remember one sort of at the
front yeah there's one at the back two
one at the back yeah
um
I don't know just something different I
think I done bleaching my bloody here
some of those didn't attend not the
greatest that I think one year I was
rocking bloody the old orange hit uh mop
um but uh yeah when we started seeing
nimir myself and I thought we'll try and
start a new new trending a good deal
blotch of uh blonde ear and I put one
down down the back my only headers in
the front so I might actually cut a
couple of his um dreads off so that it
could actually throw a bunny here and
have a little bit of a mohawk but still
be able to put the blonde patch in there
I'll bring it back
but I think I've still got a patch where
my grays are now is
because
but it was just something different the
other one I was going to do but um
ghetto had done it was I was going to
try and do a do the old cross oh yeah
yeah strip but then I saw it away
with the uh patches
okay mix one
um what do you remember about the Robbie
fruen fend
I actually thought that he was not my
man I was like piddling thinking that I
think it might have been yeah
might have been inside me and I thought
like in my head I was thinking that's
not my man that's not my man
and then
looked up he was coming at me so I
thought oh this isn't gonna be
Pleasant he was thinking you are his man
yeah hard so I just yeah
I just gotta put up put on my arms yeah
that's it that's all you remember oh
pretty much oh no I remember getting up
and saying to the boys because the boys
used to give me should have been and I'm
like yeah all good but did you see what
happened after all you guys saw was uh
me getting bumped off but it was it
actually helped get a tune over there
bro
everyone being distracted guy because I
got bumped off and we turned the ball
over and I started running it started
wrecking Robbie
but I kid you know we had a we had a uh
Camp earlier this year for our rugby
boys and um we had like a kind of like
quiz night and that showed up they they
um thought we actually put that that
clip up and uh I was like don't worry
about that worry about like what
happened next he showed what happened
next and they were all like wow what the
hell are you doing there
these don't know nothing about wrecking
boys
you know no you don't want to know what
that is all about I think I still have a
few scars from all the racket that I got
from my career
Jesus imagine if that was still going
these days racking oh imagine that hey
I was at the very end of it it just sort
of come out but in the club footy scene
that was his favorite thing to do wasn't
it not even
kept out of school yeah exactly you've
got the old massive scarves like someone
bloody whooped you yeah oh good times uh
okay I don't remember this tackle either
but did not Nano ever apologize after
his shoulder charge you to that next
year versus the Landers
oh yeah yeah I remember that I ducked a
tackle from Rory boss boss bet out of
the Rock
and I went to passing in horrible to to
tackle me and I I didn't know how I got
out of it I ducked under it
um broke through and I knew obviously
Nuggie was there
um so I tried to make sure I tried to
push off leggy so I can try and get off
what did he get up I said you tried
getting up when there's a truck that
hits you you wouldn't be getting up
there quickly
but yeah if I was thinking how am I
going to get this guy back after all
these years
so even though we were best mates you
know he was on the other end of the
field and then yeah I caught the mess of
it from skunks
um but then we he caught up afterwards
sorry I was like you're not sorry there
was your one chance to put ahead on me I
know how this this works and your mates
are in the other side like Beast mates
you try and put a head on them no matter
what whether it's legit or not
but yeah I remember I remember I've seen
a video of my uh my eldest girl
um when that happened in the video of
her she was quite young at the time it's
just cute too and she's like Uncle
butter hurt my dad
but honestly I remember that it was it
was pretty funny and saw at the same
time
okay last one best piece of advice you
have for a woodland listener
oh it depends if it's uh
and down the path of um
being a sports person
um
I guess you know
similar to what my upbringing was play
as many sports as possible
um try not to fixate yourself on on one
sport because
the amount of learnings you get from
from different codes
um I play basketball
growing up wasn't the greatest but you
know the learnings I got from
being able to
um
you know learn about structures and how
it works you know things like that and
then you go away and play games by Touch
where you're learning how to beat
players individually or you're trying to
suck people in so that when they do come
out you can throw long balls to
whoever's open on the edges
um to even nipple I played a lot of
nipple growing up indoor in outdoor
um and it was just
all the learnings that I got from every
code that I that I played in
sort of helped me see
different different things so if it's a
if it's a kid coming coming through
college you know
don't be so stuck on playing one sport
like honestly if you watch
um play if you know how to play with
Instinct it's because their background
is I've played flag touch
basketball
um anything to sort of help shape who
they are they even play soccer because
you know you might be dominant in your
right foot but the more time spent
kicking above your left foot making it
so so natural I mean you're looking
Johnny Wilkinson and dizzy when when
they go to their bad League it doesn't
even look like it's their bad lead yeah
yeah you know they're so accurate and
when they do shank it you're just like
okay maybe you just didn't uh you felt
rushed and then hurried into making that
kick but
I think I said piece of us like for me
continue to do what you do when you're a
kid play as many sports uh as you did
learn off older people because
you know you never know I use
all my learnings through rugby when I do
speaking engagements to to talk about
culture
um
team culture you know hard times
you know mental battles that I had with
myself
um you know I learned so much for
everybody
um and that wasn't just because I played
footy I played you know all these other
sports to help me understand how to read
body language of players on the field
or even on a court and try and execute
something to make it
make it work in their team's favor right
but yeah I remember one thing was from I
think it was Michael Jones He said
reach for the moon and if you don't get
there you will always be among stars so
I've killed it I've always kept it kid
there since then so I've always tried to
aim high and if I don't quite achieve
where I need to be I know you're going
to be around some great people mate I
like that even though the stars are
above the Moon that is still a great
quote
but that is probably why you're going to
be one of the best mentors I think I've
um Wellington College will ever see that
is some great advice there to finish
what has been one of the best podcasts
ever almost two hours of
one of the best Journeys and careers I I
think we've had on the podcast I really
appreciate you giving up your time mate
you were you're an idol of mine growing
up um for the canes I used to love
watching you play so instinctive like
we've spoken about
um really just read the game so well and
um awesome to sit down and have a yarn
with you and go through your journey and
reflect on some pretty special memories
not all right thanks for having me I've
uh thoroughly enjoyed actually
you know just yawning mate one of the
greats appreciate it all right thanks
cuz